hey guys Pete here so this is going to
be my episode six of mr. robot season
one recap and review I mentioned in the
last review that the whole Fernando Vera
storyline was not really my favorite
when I watched this at the first time
and this episode kind of revolves around
him and his situation so it definitely
wasn't one of my favorite episodes when
I first watched it and it's still not
one of my favorites out of the mall but
it's really not as bad because of the
way things resolved the reason I didn't
like it at first and still don't much
like it is that it always seemed like
there was just no way that it could work
out to me it seemed like once Vera knew
that he turned him in he had the upper
hand especially once he had control of
Shayla so it just seemed like it was a I
mean there is a good character he's
interesting and all of that it was just
that with him being in jail it seemed
like a real sidetrack from what eff
society was trying to do now in this
episode we see that he does just that he
has Shayla we get to see the
introduction in the very beginning where
he has his henchman show her sort of
been the proof of life to Eliot and
Eliot gets a chance to apologize if
nothing else for what happened but then
you know I mean the whole idea of
breaking him out of jail seems a little
far-fetched and be that as it may that's
what ends up happening and we see some
interesting stuff and how they do it
it's not totally unbelievable I guess it
just seems like sort of the kind of
thing that you would have seen happen a
lot in the real world if it was possible
to do so we see him work with Darlene
and we see that she makes them a
critical error due to the time frame we
see this interesting little scenario
where he has her go and drop a bunch of
thumb drives or USB drives around the
corrections department and someone picks
them up and that gives them a chance to
get to exploit onto the system but then
she used a known exploit I guess is the
best way to describe that and it was
picked up by the anti-malware software
that the prison ran so elliott spends
most of the seat or the episode with his
back against the wall trying to figure
out how to
mara Al and he is able to pull it off by
hacking a laptop in a police car but
then whenever things all said and done
Vera had killed Shayla anyways that was
tough it was definitely tough it was a
well acted scene when we see Elliot's
reaction we know that this is probably
the last thing that kept him kind of in
reality I guess you could say you know
the Shayla was the one positive
influence in his life and now he's
pretty much I would you know at the end
of this at what you think is he's
probably spiraling out of control so
that is something that needed to happen
I guess you know it's something that we
had to see happen in order for him to
get moving in that direction much in the
same way the data dump was when you
think about it after the fact I mean she
kind of had to die what would they be
able to what would she be able to bring
to the story beyond that point would
they have had a relationship would it
have turned into something I mean for
the trajectory that he's on with this
hack that he's trying to pull off with F
Society she doesn't really fit into the
picture beyond that I didn't realize
that early on but after seeing her dead
then I realized that well that's sort of
the only way that could have ended but I
liked it when they were together I liked
her and it was a good character and if
nothing else had showed us that Elliot
has some things that we might not
realize otherwise like he is capable of
caring for someone and being affected on
that level by someone I guess you could
say that it made him human in a way
because a lot of his interactions with
us are very logical very laid out in his
thought process so it gave him some
balance but it was really more important
I guess to knock her off to put him over
the edge so the main part on didn't
really move that much here because we
sort of went off on this tangent but
there is a lot of foreshadowing of
what's to come I mean obviously we see
as a result of the tragedy that Shayla
actually knew more about what was the
right thing to do than Elliot did he
went and did his thing and it ended up
being a terrible mistake you know by
trying to stop Vera he ended up getting
Shayla killed and that was her concern
right
so at the end of the last episode we saw
that Angela had come across this idea
that her father was in a lot of debt
even though evil Corp was responsible
for killing her mother basically now her
father was in debt and was had all these
final notices and everything else for
paying for her insurance so she decides
to dig through the data dump and starts
contacting law the lawyers that were
involved in the original case that got
thrown out there's only one of them that
call her back she gets excited she goes
down but then the lawyer kind of puts
her in her place we get a little look
into what's up with this lawyer she's
drinking with her morning tea I mean
it's early in the morning we know that
because we saw Angela's time on her
computer so I guess that opens the door
where the other ones hadn't but she says
it took her eight years to get her
career back on track after that case got
thrown out she shows Angela just how
difficult this is gonna be she shows her
this guy who's been twice convicted of
sexual assault sitting in the hallway
tells her the situation where he had
assaulted his pregnant girlfriend with
an xbox because when they were playing
something happened something trivial
happened and she says to Angela
point-blank I will have an easier time
defending him than going up against evil
Corp this isn't a big surprise to us as
viewers but it does sort of underscore
just how massive and dangerous evil Corp
is it's the largest conglomerate in
history according to the lawyer so you
know it's not going to be easy by any
stretch of the imagination sure they had
this information from Colby but when we
see Angela go visit him she's not even
able to initiate any kind of talks
because that's just how the kind of guy
he is Angela does go and meet Elliot
quickly and this is right in the middle
of when he's trying to figure out how to
hack the prison and she says something
that's pretty interesting she says we
always knew what evil Corp did we didn't
have the proof but we knew I have an
idea that will change the world I know
it sounds really stupid but I know how
to do it I think it could actually work
and this is a
call back to Elliot telling us that he's
trying to change the world and why
that's you know not to be mad at him for
his slip Elliot doesn't really have time
to deal with it so he just tells her to
do what she thinks is right and we see
that they're on similar paths but in two
different ways Elliot's trying to bring
evil Corp down by the hacking them and
she's trying to do it through the legal
system we get Tyrell and Scott Knowles
we find out that Tyrells little walking
into the bathroom thing with Sharon
Knowles has backfired on him he goes to
see Scott and Scott pretty much owns him
rates him we see Tyrell at home later
freaking out although joanna is pretty
cool and collected she's having herself
a snack and doesn't seem to feel the
urgency that her husband does but they
are in a compromised position now Tyrell
was the interim CTO and Scott Knowles is
now going to take over his job so he's
going to be Tyrells boss and none of
them what he's done to this point is
going to be good for him the actor who
plays Knowles is quite good and you'll
see that more and it's a pretty powerful
scene it's pretty good and knocks Tyrell
down but I think of the two the more
interesting one is Joanna's reaction and
the scene at home we see what a team
they are and how they complement each
other the thing about the Scott Knowles
thing that I remember that stood out to
me at this point is is that you realize
that he kind of was introduced as a goof
almost with his wine and all that they
kind of just didn't really pay him a lot
of respect he didn't become the CTO of
the largest conglomerate in history by
not knowing how to play the game so
that's really with the big takeaway
there I had asked a couple episodes back
in the reviews or the recaps that if you
guys have starting to wonder about
whether things are real or not and I did
when I watched this the first time I
wondered about the Shayla scene you know
we find out she's dead but they're
really not away from Elliot at any point
after that so I kind of wondered if that
whole thing was imagine his converse
mishaela they've certainly left the door
open for Vera returning and causing
problems but he's for the most part I
would say that they pretty much tied up
that whole storyline with a nice bow
Angela and Tyrell are the two
interesting things that pop out of this
Tyrell is like I said he's in a
compromised position and he Scott
basically showed him that he has like he
had you know he owns his position there
so you know that makes you wonder how
he's going to react and Angela was able
to talk her way in with the lawyer and
the information is good but they're
probably going to need a lot more to be
able to actually move the case forward
so that's about it for this episode
it is a middle-of-the-road one for me
although obviously the heart-wrenching
death of Shayla is important and even
though we haven't seen anything move
forward with eff society we've
definitely seen some things going with
Angela having a similar motivation now
that she's trying to take on Ecore /
self let me know what you guys think in
the comments we're really getting close
now to season 3 so I'm getting pretty
pumped up make sure you like this video
if you enjoyed it subscribe to my
channel I'll be doing weekly videos for
mr. robot all through season 3 make sure
you turn on notifications so you see the
videos when they come out follow me on
Twitter and my other social media
accounts so that we can get together
over there thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon